one million users in one year this is
what a new email client named skiff has
managed to do of course this is nothing
in comparison to Gmail total user
account of 1.8 billion users but this is
also what makes gifs so impressive in an
era where Gmail is ubiquitous scaf has
managed to grow to a million users from
scratch within a matter of months on
paper skiff doesn't offer anything
remarkable per se there are just an
encrypted email client with a solid UI
what's even more interesting is that
skiff is able to get away with the much
more traditional Avenue of monetization
nowadays all the craze is to make
everything free and come up with super
creative ways to monetize users whether
that be collecting data or running ads I
mean it this was literally the selling
factor of Gmail a free invite-only email
with extraordinary storage capacity but
this comes with its own set of
disadvantages for one Google is an ad
company who makes money by getting to
know you as well as possible and what
better way to get to know you than
reading our emails this was actually a
big controversy back in the day and
Google apparently stopped reading our
emails back in 2017 but certain smart
features suggest the opposite so you can
take that for what you will skiff on the
other hand it can't read your emails
even if they wanted to because
everything is end to end encrypted as
such they have turned to a more archaic
mode of monetization where people
actually paid a company directly for the
service maybe some of you are too young
to know about this but this is how
companies used to do business and skiff
is trying to bring this model back to
one of the most competitive Industries
in the world while they do have a
generous free tier with 10 gigabytes of
storage and even custom domain support
the only way they make money is from
people who spring for the essential or
Pro tier given their user account though
it doesn't seem like this is really
slowing down their adoption they even
have some super notable users like
vitalik buterin the founder of ethereum
but it's not all sunshines and rainbows
to get to this point skip has had to
raise over 14 million dollars also while
GIF does have quite a bit of momentum
right now it's not clear if they'll be
able to maintain this momentum after
they burn through the privacy and
ui-centric folks the reality is that
while the average person would like to
have more privacy they're also too lazy
to change anything they're currently
doing so join me as we take a look at
whether Escape is truly the next big
thing or if it's just a niche product
that'll never be more than just that
foreign
the main appealing factors of skiff are
pretty simple and it's probably the best
looking male client on the market and it
has privacy that even experts seem to
like in fact all of Skip's code is open
source so if you're a coder you can take
a look at exactly what the platform
tracks how it encrypts your emails and
whether they're actually being honest
even if you're not a coder you can rest
assured that everything truly is private
as Russia has given it the seal of
approval by Banning it skiff is also
trying to address traditional
shortcomings regarding mail filters and
centralization but really the selling
factors are the UI and privacy that's
pretty much it but oftentimes that's all
you need when you're addressing
something as established as email
there's really not much you can change
but that's okay you don't need to
revolutionize email you just have to
make email noticeably better I mean this
has been Google Secret Sauce the entire
time they were never first to anything
they did there were plenty of search
engines before Google plenty of emails
here for Gmail and plenty of browsers
before Chrome fun fact Google's own CEO
Eric Schmidt was strongly opposed to
building Chrome as he thought that
entering the browser Wars was futile in
fact he single-handedly delayed a launch
of chrome by 6 years but that didn't
stop Chrome from being the biggest
success the browser space has ever seen
the truth is that while first movers do
indeed have an advantage that's all it
is an advantage it's not an endless
Monopoly over a certain domain I mean
Chad GPT is disrupting Google as we
speak which brings us into our next
point for skip which is the sentiment
surrounding Google one of the biggest
reasons that Google was so successful
was because of their Underdog nature
people love to support this crappy
startup that was Google their motto of
don't be evil resonated with users why
support Hotmail and Internet Explorer
products from the evil Tech Monopoly
Microsoft when you could support Google
but while this worked in Google's favor
back in the 2000s this is no longer the
case today Google is very much the
evotech Monopoly that Microsoft was back
in the day meaning that Google is primed
for disruption I mean just take a look
at how quick people were to laugh at
Bard sure Bard made a mistake but if
Google was still a scrappy startup I bet
people would have focused on the
millions of items that Barr did
correctly as opposed to the few that or
didn't but since Google is a giant the
sentiment is oh Google is a trillion
dollar Monopoly and they can't even get
this right what a joke the shift in
sentiment is subtle but it makes all the
difference all of a sudden a service
like skiff that actually respects her
privacy is worth a shot what's the worst
that could happen it sucks and you come
back to Gmail clearly not very high
stakes speaking of high stakes skiff
doesn't have a very high barrier for
entry either one of the advantages of
entering an established Market is that
people are already familiar with their
product people already know why email is
useful how to send an email what TC and
BCC mean so skip doesn't have to
convince people on adopting in email
itself they just have to convince people
that skiff is the best platform for
email and given that most people are
relatively tech savvy nowadays getting
them to give it a shot isn't too hard
this is why we see so many apps blow up
basically overnight in fact if you truly
have a winning product it's easier to go
viral today than ever before Tick Tock
gained 100 million users within a matter
of nine months more recently chatgpt was
able to Garner 100 million users within
just two months 20 years ago such
traction would have been impossible
regardless of how good the part was
nowadays information is simply shared
and absorbed so quickly that if you have
momentum on your side you can go
extremely far so trying to challenge
even something as big as Gmail is very
much possible but there's of course some
pretty big hurdles along the way as well
likely the biggest elephant in the room
is who cares nowadays we all see
articles about Facebook and Google and
basically every other company invading
our privacy and while I do believe that
everyone should have the right to
privacy realistically speaking I think
the vast majority of us have just become
numb to the idea I mean is having a
truly private email really going to
change anything are you also going to
find alternatives for Instagram and
YouTube and Google search and Tick Tock
and basically everything else as well
I'm gonna guess probably not this isn't
to say that these companies are in the
right for collecting data on all of us
but I guess it's simply a reality that
most of us have just come to accept so
it's not clear if the Privacy argument
will really hit as well as you might
think speaking of privacy and it's also
not clear how much people actually care
about privacy when it comes to email in
general I don't know about you but
virtually all of my email used is
professional the last time I actually
emailed a friend was like 2011. so
there's not not anything especially
personal that I sent through email that
I would want to protect to begin with
and I suspect it's the same case with
most people most people just use email
for work or school to contact co-workers
managers professors and so on or they
use it to sign up for newsletters and
create accounts but very rarely do
people use email for social
communication so again not sure how much
people will care about privacy here
something else to note is that people
don't really choose what email client
they use for work or school unless it's
like the Apple Mail app they just use
whatever the school or company uses
Skip's new feature that allows people to
use a custom domain for free does
technically make this possible but we'll
have to see how many people actually
care to take advantage of this also
there is no way we can discuss the
future of skiff without mentioning
protonmail if you're not familiar with
protonmail it's basically just an older
skiff protonmail launched back in 2014
with the promise of better privacy and a
more refined UI and they're doing pretty
good they have over 70 million count but
this brings up the question what does
GIF really offer over protonmail well we
can't really make an argument based on
UI because that's subjective and to be
honest they both have a great modern UI
so it's really just personal preference
there's also of course some minor
differences in terms of pricing and
features but really the main difference
seems to be the encryption standard
protonmail uses something called it pgp
encryption which has been the standard
for decades skiff argues that pgp is
outdated and that there are far better
encryption standards out there and they
could be absolutely right but how many
people would actually care or even know
about this as far as the average user is
concerned both email clients are
end-to-end encrypted also all email
clients will claim that they have the
best encryption so unless you really
understand these encryption standards it
doesn't really mean anything to the
average person and all of that brings us
into live face gives bigger shortfall
which is monetization every dominant
email that has ever existed has come
from a tech giant whether that be AOL
Yahoo Microsoft or Google and the main
reason for that is that email simply
works much better as a side business
than a main business you simply have to
reach extraordinary skill to start
making any sort of profit protonmail for
example is only possible because of the
generosity of its community and it seems
that the only reason that skiff and
their generous free tiers are possible
are because of insane VC money VCS are
willing to go quite far nowadays in
terms of funding but it's not the same
as Google launching Gmail in 2004 and
subsidizing the cost themselves as far
as Google is concerned even if Gmail is
a break even effort indefinitely Or even
as light laws that's a massive win 1.8
billion users are even more integrated
into the Google ecosystem for skiff on
the other hand monetization has to
eventually work out and they have to
fundraise in the meantime otherwise
they're toast
foreign
while launching a new email client in
the 2020s may seem crazy it's actually
way more viable than you might think the
sentiment against Google paired with the
insane virality potential of modern apps
makes a new email client quite viable
combine this with some extra privacy and
a better UI and the skiff may very well
have a winning product on their hands
but their success is by no means
guaranteed several companies have picked
up on this trend of adding privacy and
UI to replace offerings from Big tech
companies some other examples are signal
be real and protonmail some of these
anti-big Tech offerings end up panning
out while others end up dead in the
water only time will tell if skiff has
enough Mojo to convince the general
public to make the switch schools are
already ditching Google in general so
that may be an opportunity for skiff
check out this video to learn more about
why schools are ditching Google but
until then I'm Hari and I'll say guys on
the next one
[Music]